un refus affiché au grand jour ce jeudi
une trentaine d'élus et de citoyens se
sont rassemblés à montesquieu objectif
dénoncer le tracé de la ligne à grande
vitesse reliant bordeaux à toulouse pour
le maire de la commune cette future lgv
n'apportera que des dégâts il y a un
impact sur la commune qui est
catastrophique on va dire
catastrophiques dans le niveau othamot
niveau cultures agricoles que le niveau
flore faune biodiversité et on parle
beaucoup de biodiversité à ce moment et
là on sera peut-être pas compte de la
gravité de cette de ce tracé un tracé
perçu comme destructeur par certains
habitants de la commune qui pourrait
perdre près de 75 hectares de terre
c'est le cas de pascal roques un
exploitant agricole dans l'impasse le
nouveau tracé de la lgv coupe son
exploitation en deux on s'oppose pas
forcément à la lgv on se pose au dernier
tracé de la lgv qui nous est imposée
aujourd'hui puisque c'est un tracé qui
va à l'encontre de l'écologie de la
biodiversité et des agriculteurs c'est
un tracé qui va détruire une grosse
partie de mon territoire de l'alluré et
en l'occurrence moi personnellement je
suis agriculteur avec une exploitation
qui se trouve au pied de la vallée de la
garonne et le tracé lgv va traverser
transversale barbon l'exploitation et
m'anéantir et je pourrais dire me
détruire totalement aussi bien au niveau
de la production qu'au niveau économique
une décision illogique pour bon nombre
d'habitants à quelques kilomètres de là
françoise propriétaire du château de
tranquille et on se bat depuis plusieurs
années contre ce projet classé monument
historique
son château fera désormais face un pont
d'une hauteur impressionnante
ici nous sommes donc très impactées par
cette lgv puisque nous allons avoir un
viaduc qui va passer dans le périmètre
protégé du château et donc au pied du
château est là
sur
68 mètres de haut sur 1 km 8 ça veut
dire que nous allons avoir des bruits
inferno et surtout une nuisance en plus
visuel le conseil d'état a rejeté un
recours présenté par une association
locale contre le tracé de la lgv
pourtant les habitants du village ne
décolère pas ils placent leurs derniers
espoirs dans l'interpellation des
pouvoirs publics